Speaker 1: So earlier this week, we kind of
hit on pretty hard because they deserve it.
And is this wacky right wing propaganda network?
And I think I said in the segment.
Speaker 2: Fox News is right wing propaganda.
Speaker 1: Newsmax is extreme right wing propaganda,
and OANN is like completely insane right wing
propaganda.
And I even said, compared to Joanne, Newsmax
sometimes will sound
Speaker 2: sort of a little bit reasonable.
Speaker 1: Today, I have an example of Newsmax
not sounding even at all reasonable.
And this is a really instructive segment.
I'm going to play for you, one of the most
hilariously and horrifyingly
Speaker 2: ignorant segments that I've ever
seen.
I would say
Speaker 1: on any network, I don't know that
I've ever seen a one minute
Speaker 2: segment with such ignorance.
Speaker 1: There is a Newsmax host named Chris
Saucedo Saucedo.
I actually think I've been on his show before,
I if I'm thinking of the same guy used to
have a radio show, maybe Philly, I don't remember.
Speaker 2: I think the interview I did with
him
Speaker 1: on his radio show might even be
on our website in the press section.
From what I recall, he was much less ignorant
back then.
The ignorance was less weaponized, although
it was still bad.
I don't know if what I'm about to play for
you are his genuine views or what he has to
do to be on the
Speaker 2: good boy list at OANN.
Speaker 1: But he went on a rant yesterday.
Speaker 2: Climate change
Speaker 1: denial rant.
I can't make heads or tails out of it.
I don't know how someone can
Speaker 2: beat this dumb
Speaker 1: and again,
Speaker 2: he might not be done.
This might just be overt propaganda.
It's like brain rot of some kind like his.
Speaker 1: His head is filled with mayonnaise
or honey mustard or something.
It's almost like his brain
Speaker 2: fell out of his head.
So let me play the clip.
Speaker 1: Listen to the mind blowingly ignorant
and incorrect things that he says here.
And then we're going to break it down piece
by piece
Speaker 3: as to the science of the socialists
religion from experts I have read and interviewed
over the years.
I can say that there is no proof that man
CO2 emissions are destroying the planet.
If that were the case, the world would have
invaded communist China long ago.
They build one so-called dirty coal fired
plant on average every week.
If China's CO2 emissions were destroying all
life on Mother Earth and China is the world's
number one CO2 emitter, why would Obama, Biden
and the rest of the American Left leave China
alone and instead destroy the United States
manufacturing base and our energy production?
Joe Biden claims that warmer temperatures
make weather more destructive.
That has not been proven.
What has been proven is that warmer weather
results in more food production, less starvation
and less death.
What has been proven is that the Earth has
been at this temperature before back in the
medieval period.
Not too many coal plants and SUVs trolling
around at that
Speaker 2: time, right?
So you
Speaker 1: really have to slow down
Speaker 2: and think about each
Speaker 1: aspect of this one at a time.
The mind blowing stupidity is notable, but
the wildest
Speaker 2: aspect is he almost
Speaker 1: seems like proud that he's saying
this stuff on TV.
He genuinely seems to think it's clever.
So let's go through it piece by piece.
He talks about
Speaker 2: science, the
Speaker 1: socialists religion.
You can make the case that sometimes people
allow dogmatism to enter their view of science,
and when that happens, we should criticize
it.
Speaker 2: But science is
Speaker 1: not a religion, and when when people
Speaker 2: say science is
Speaker 1: your religion, you can believe
in Christianity or you can believe in science.
That's very much wrong because science exists
and is the same regardless of whether you
believe in it or not.
Nobody believed in Christianity.
Christianity disappears,
Speaker 2: right?
Science encourages being corrected, fixing
Speaker 1: mistakes and has self-correction
mechanisms.
And in fact,
Speaker 2: when you make the bigger,
Speaker 1: the correction you make in science,
the bigger the accolades, the more revered
Speaker 2: you are.
Speaker 1: Religion doesn't have that.
Speaker 2: Self-correction is not revered
in religion.
Speaker 1: So these analogies science is the
religion of socialists.
Maybe there's some dogmatic people when it
comes to science
Speaker 2: is very, very different than a
religion.
Speaker 1: He says experts that I've read
and interviewed say there's no proof that
CO2 from man is destroying the planet.
It's always hyperbolic and there's always
some semantic game, right?
Speaker 2: So, OK, well,
Speaker 1: destroying the planet is a big
statement.
The scientific
Speaker 2: consensus is
Speaker 1: very clear that elevated CO2 caused
by industrial activity.
Now, would they say, well, humans didn't do
that.
The factories did it.
That's a distinction without a difference.
That is bad for the planet
Speaker 2: in many ways.
Its effect
Speaker 1: on climate.
Its effect on the ozone
Speaker 2: layer accelerating the
Speaker 1: greenhouse effect.
This is the scientific consensus.
Speaker 2: Could it be wrong?
It could.
Speaker 1: Many people right now are trying
to disprove it.
Speaker 2: None have been able
Speaker 1: to so far remains the best explanation
we have right now.
That's how science works, he says.
Speaker 2: If CO2 were
Speaker 1: really this bad, we would have
invaded communist China by now.
You know, the issue of China's pollution is
a huge
Speaker 2: topic in and of itself, and it
kind of
Speaker 1: exceeds our scope today.
But it is absurdly simplistic to say if CO2
were really bad, we would invade China.
It's so dumb.
It's kind of hard to refute.
Adults don't really think in this way.
He then argues
Speaker 2: that CO2
Speaker 1: emissions aren't really destroying
all life on Earth.
Well, we're not saying that.
That's what it is.
It's sort of again, the
Speaker 2: argument isn't all life
Speaker 1: on Earth today is being destroyed
by CO2, it's a straw man or a red herring.
He argues that warmer temperatures are good
because if it's warmer, you get more food
growth.
Speaker 2: It's really complicated, but understand
that when it's
Speaker 1: unseasonably warm, if you don't
have more rain to go with it, you get drought.
And drought is not good for crops.
Speaker 2: It kills crops
Speaker 1: or you've got to go and find more
water to raise the same amount of food.
That's also not good for the environment,
so warmer being better for food production.
Also, not true.
And then he says Earth has been at this temperature
before, before we had modern industry.
That's true.
There have been periods of warming on Earth
before, but temperatures are only one part
of what's going on.
CO2 in the atmosphere has never been this
high.
Speaker 2: That's a big piece of it.
The fact that it's been
Speaker 1: warm before doesn't prove or disprove
anything.
So it took me, what, seven minutes?
This is like two plus two equals five type
of stuff, and it takes a while to disprove
it.
Sam Harris said.
And on this, he's completely right.
It's very easy to start a series of small
fires that are really time consuming to put
out.
It's much easier to start the fires than to
put them out.
And unfortunately, whether Chris Saucedo believes
this stuff or he knows he's just feeding his
audience,
Speaker 2: the drivel
Speaker 1: and pabulum that they so
Speaker 2: desperately want,
Speaker 1: some of his audience falls for
it and believes it.
Speaker 2: And now we're sitting here trying
to undo it really, really bad.
Speaker 1: And I mean, it's like his brain
left his his cranium.
Really scary stuff.
A, we have a we have two things going on.
Number one, the town hall rescheduled for
December 28th due to technical difficulties.
Six p.m. December 28th.
I hope you'll join us.
It'll definitely be the last one of the year.
Also, January 1st, we'll be doing a one day
Speaker 2: membership bomb,
Speaker 1: kicking off an election year with
a huge membership discount.
I would love for you to participate.
All you need to do today is sign up for my
mailing list at David Pakman dot com and then
on the 1st, you'll be notified about exactly
how to avail yourself
Speaker 2: of this incredible membership discount.
Speaker 1: All right, remember that the David
Pakman show it depends on your support.
You can sign up and join Packman dot com.
We do an extra show every day for our members,
called the bonus show.
You can get
Speaker 2: access to it simply by
Speaker 1: signing up at join Packman dot
com.
Also, we include commercial free
Speaker 2: audio and video streams of show,
Speaker 1: all of it available at a very,
very low rate.
You can sign up at Join Packman dot com and
use the coupon code better 21 to shave pretty
solid portion off of that.
Speaker 2: Encourage you to do that.